après plus d'un mois d'absence la pluie
a fait son retour depuis quelques jours
en Touraine des précipitations dans la
moyenne du mois de mars et pour
l'instant insuffisant pour recharger les
nappes phréatiques l'Agence de l'Eau
prépare déjà un plan à destination des
collectivités et des entreprises et des
explications de la Turquie
le beau temps est de retour après
plusieurs jours de pluie de l'eau enfin
depuis début mars entre 40 et 50 mm sont
tombés en Indre-et-Loire bonne nouvelle
mais est-ce suffisant pour remplir les
nappes phréatiques en ce début d'année
le département présente un déficit en
eau de 27% à la même période
était meilleur donc là pour le moment on
n'est pas dans une bonne situation
maintenant tout va dépendre de si on
arrive à garder un temps qui est voilà
un peu arrosé même si c'est moins
efficace qu'on garde une certaine
humidité en surface pour les nappes je
pense que on n'arrivera pas à vous dire
à la normale cette année en mars
2000 en Touraine les nappes phréatiques
étaient estimées à un niveau en dessous
de la moyenne
aujourd'hui le curseur devient orange et
le niveau est bas conséquence de
l'épisode de sécheresse de février et de
l'été dernier on a on a consommé nos
réserves en quelque sorte et on a plus
de stock donc si la les conditions
climatiques de 2023 ressemblent à celle
de 2022 on sait déjà on sera sur
certains territoires en difficulté donc
il faut plus que jamais anticiper et
donc il faut réduire notre consommation
d'eau l'Agence de l'Eau Loire Bretagne
vient d'ailleurs de voter un plan de
résilience un investissement d'une
centaine de millions d'euros pour
accompagner les collectivités et les
entreprises à réduire leur consommation
d'eau